welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman all of this
week
let's talk about january 6. shall we
obviously in the last few weeks here
we've gotten some
very important news i would call it
about the events of that day the events
before that day the powerpoints the text
messages the emails the phone calls
all kinds of stuff
but some of the most important
information we've gotten about january 6
has actually come from the courts
late last week
the harshest sentence to date for one of
the capitol rioters was handed down the
man who assaulted a police officer with
a fire extinguisher sentenced to a
little more than five years in prison
and of course this individual expressed
his uh
sorrow his sadness
at what he did you know
got the crocodile tears going um
but
judge didn't buy it
still sentence him to more than five
years
and this is
becoming routine at this point
this is what we're seeing happening
with these judges in the sentences that
they're handing down
and here's why and this is very
important and this is something that
everybody needs to understand
about the cases these judges are hearing
because judges are telling us this past
week
that january 6 is it's not over it's not
over
and the reason for that is because what
radicalized these individuals has not
stopped it has not gone away
while these particular people the the
ones who have been sentenced the ones
who are going to jail are currently in
jail they're probably not as likely to
engage in that kind of behavior in the
future
we're still creating another army
essentially
of these crazed people who think the
election was stolen
and that's what january 6 was
here's another thing
i filled in for david
back in august one of the stories i
talked about at the time i remember it
vividly
was the fact that judges back in august
were telling us
that we're probably facing another
january sixth type six uh situation
because of the radicalization process
because the big lie still persisted out
there
and in fact because it was being pushed
even harder in august than it was in
january
and now here we are four and a half
months after those judges told us that
more judges came out in the past week
and effectively told us the same thing
that we can expect more we can expect
worse
and we can expect this because the
radicalization still exists
because nothing has been done to stop it
because honestly it's hard to stop it
right these people have free speech we
can't tell them they're not allowed to
say these things that's illegal
but they're also not being held
accountable by the media outlets who
allow them to say these things
on their social media platforms where
they spew these lies every day in the
speeches that they give and again part
of this is because there's literally
nothing we can do about it all we can do
is go out there every day and talk about
how this is a lie this is not true all
of the evidence including the
uh audits and investigations conducted
by conservative groups are all telling
us there's no fraud there was no theft
but even still 70 percent of the
republican party believes joe biden is
not the dually elected president of the
united states
that the 2020 election was stolen 70
percent of republicans believe that now
and if we had listened to these judges
months ago
that wouldn't come as a shock
what happened on january 6th
was kind of an immediate radicalization
of individuals who were most of them
probably kind of already on the edge
they were hardcore supporters they had
their feelings hurt that their guy
didn't win
and then he told them go fight like hell
or you won't have a country anymore
hell one of the accused rioters last
week in in in front of a judge said
trump gave me permission to do this
i had a right to storm the capitol
because the former president gave me
permission
so they took that that one statement
from him and well the rest of it as well
that was their action and they went with
it
that's how quickly that radicalization
happened for many of those individuals
for the rest of them we're talking about
radicalization that's been going on for
a year now
radicalization that is taking hold
within the republican party to the point
70 percent look at joe biden and say
that man who i also think is incompetent
somehow stole the election
for the record two things can't be true
there he can't be such an incompetent
idiot you know he can't even stay awake
and a mastermind who stole the 2020
election that makes no sense
yet this is what they believe
and the judges are still out there
warning us that yeah things are going to
get bad again things are probably going
to be worse than what they already were
because nothing's being done
and in many instances there's nothing
legal we can do about it
all we can do is fight back against the
misinformation
and as somebody who does do this every
day and i'm sure david feels the same
way sometimes it feels like this
sisyphean task
we're pushing this boulder up the hill
only to watch it roll back down again
and start all over
there's no end there's no there's no
clear victory here
we're just destined to do this forever
to fight back against this conservative
misinformation
but like sisyphus himself we're never
going to stop
that's part of our job it's what we do
it's how we help
so that's what we're doing here
that's what these judges are trying to
do they're giving us the warnings
and if we don't heed these warnings
then yeah we're probably going to be
looking at something much worse than
what happened on january 6th at some
point
in the future